[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to did you
all see the remake of Beauty and the
Beast I never once got some pipes on her
huh she's just like a well-oiled car and
that there's certainly been a lot of
auto tuning oh I can feel your anger
acting is swelling in you now regardless
of your thoughts on this movie did well
most people can agree that Emma Watson
is no page O'Hara I want that I'm sure
in her grief life somewhere but if you
can't think it better in an entertaining
ly unique way why sing it at all this is
not the first time in the past several
years we've asked this question big-name
actors like the rock and the stone
pierce brosnan fund I'm Java and of
course our darling little song crow all
that singing voices most people would
agree are not bad musically impressive
at least certainly not strong enough to
survive in musical theater for years
though this wasn't really seen as a
problem as when an actor good thing they
just dumped them yeah nobody even cared
if you could sing great but it's not
you're still loved you just got someone
else to sing your for Priya well
recently there's been this big thing
about not dubbing singers even if
they're not musically inclined because
of that our eardrums have paid which
you're our Butler
marlon brando but there is room for
doubt even eastwood gave it a try much
to our everlasting horror but suddenly
my words read someone else's so the big
question is if an actor is not a good
singer should they be both well look at
the pros and cons the big argument is
that if an actor is dubbed it takes away
from their performance it's not the
actor the reflections tone or even voice
so many would say we're not actually
watching the actor well admit there are
times where an obvious dub can get in
the way Jonathan Taylor with comments a
sudden voice change in Lion King is
pretty distracting well when I'm King
that'll be the first thing to go
gotta beat the main effects makeup team
was first on but then again Matthew
Broderick dubbing is almost identical so
many things to tell her but how to make
her see Cary Elwes dubbing is laughably
noticeable in quest for Camelot really
I'll have to take your word for that I
[Music]
know he's friends but George Clooney's a
no brother warth thou has made the song
a helpful favor
I don't think that song would be as big
a hit if George used his original vocals
on that one nonetheless I get the
argument what a dub is really obvious it
can take you out of the moment but if an
actor isn't a singer why have them sing
is that the whole reason we watch people
to begin with to seem do things that we
can't
Gregory Peck is impressive because he's
a better actor than most of the people
in the audience Audra McDonald is
impressive because they're singing range
is incredible compared to anyone else
most likely listening to both create an
emotional reaction with their gift of
course there are something that can do
both at the end of Menzel Julie Andrew
Hugh Jackman so let's goes on but not
for an incredibly long time most can
either act well and sing bad or act bad
as well
well star power is not quite as huge as
it used to be in the past it still
counts for a lot in movies and having a
big name can and usually does bring a
lot more people in so the idea of
putting in a big draw in a genre that's
now becoming popular again is no big
shock but forcing them to be out of
their element in a field where people
spend years tuning their gift seems
pretty unfair now don't get me wrong
Hollywood is the land of unfair but if
someone can make you cry with this
[Music]
and it's being replaced with this is the
voice of the only people are going to
notice but there is something
interesting that's happening with bad
singers and film that sometimes could
work in their favor
having charm compared for example to bad
singers in two different films
first we have Roma Crowe from Li Mis
loads let me find him
last time is she
[Music]
next we have the rock from mallanna
there's no need to play it's okay to
Moscow hop I guess it's just my way of
evening even though both of these voices
are not especially great the rock
sounded a lot better than me
look at how unfocused uncomfortable and
uninterested croci he looks like he's
more concerned about how to carry a tune
rather than being a passionate character
the rock on the other hand listen to his
inflections look at how he's animated
observe how 100% in the moment here what
can I say that you welcome well as I
click on this guy despite both these two
not being good singer
the rock is having so much more fun and
doing a much better job at sucking you
in that it doesn't even really matter
now let's switch it around let's have
another Disney song with another lame is
on and half way by no means has given
the best rendition of I dreamed a dream
there are literally dozens of other
recordings of singers with powerhouse
voices who can do it a lot better but
her performance is engaging yet you
invested makes you feel every ounce of
pain this person has gone through
[Music]
compare this to the beauty and the beat
remake report emma watson sounds like
she's reading notes in a recording
studio rather than discovering her
captor might have a redeemable humanity
sweet he was he was cool to know why
it's so cold lifeless and robotic that
of course we're going to notice the
flaws even more as well as the technical
Corrections made afterwards now I know a
lot of you really liked this movie so I
will say this role can't be portraying
Kristen Stewart portraying Belle have to
be good try to be valuable knowledge
with agile journey towards all complete
this plenty of other actors who have won
people over in a similar way despite
them not having the most phenomenal
voice Johnny Depp madness and Sweeney
Todd distract enough people to get an
Oscar nod Emma Stone actually wanted us
your despite her singing being flawed
yet beautifully vulnerable and Disney
once again helped Robin Williams
dazzling energy leap off the screen in
this larger-than-life roller coaster
[Music]
it's not great singing but it's a great
voice and sometimes that's enough Anthes
arleigh enough it can work both ways in
my fair lady Audrey Hepburn is dubbed
while Rex Harrison isn't despite Hepburn
obviously having a better voice than in
no word yet Cornish Ronnie
choir singing smack but again this isn't
what was needed for the movie her
musical sequences needed to be huge and
grand while his musical sequences need
to be snarky and witty his form of
singing is some people call it works
perfect for what's needed while
Hepburn's good but not great voice would
have weakened what was needed and her
see I get was all day through words from
him now from you know you blighters
pencil I get one sold a new purse on ten
now from you that's all you know
her voice is totally passable but it's
not huge and this sequence needed a huge
voice so yes there are times where a
good singer needs to be replaced with a
great one while a bad singer can just be
kept bad and surprisingly they can both
work sometimes though it makes it worse
in the fan of the Opera Mini driver is
dubbed despite the fact that she can
sing not great like an opera singer
which was required for the role yet
everyone else is allowed to use their
real voices despite them obviously
struggling like hell now not only do we
have non singer singing but we have an
actual professional singer to compare
them to that just makes things a million
times more awful so with all this going
back and forth what is it all about -
well maybe some actors should be dubbed
while other actors should be allowed to
sing depending on what's needed for the
movie if a non singer can pull off the
emotion of the scene stronger than a
professional singer can it makes sense
to use them if the emotion of the scene
completely rests on how well the song is
sung it should probably go to the
Department the rockin Hathaway have
emotional ups and downs that their vocal
flaws can make more effective it also
gives more leeway to hide their
weaknesses Watson and Crowes short
breaths and audio correct and can't be
hidden as well in what's supposed to be
a grand sweeping epic so it would make
sense then to dub them over especially
when we have something to compare it to
already it just makes it that much
harder to make it their own
[Music]
since I swear by God
and to those saying that dubbing takes
away from an actor's performance I'd say
it's like any other special effect some
are done great some are done poorly but
you still work with it to create an
illusion that results in a strong
emotion it doesn't matter what means you
use to get there or who did the most
work as long as the audience is engaged
by what's going on an actor doesn't
insist they do their own special effects
makeup they leave that to the
professionals yet they still have to act
with it to suck the audience in that's
exactly how dubbing is supposed to work
if it's done right there's also no shame
if someone's not a good singer a
playwright doesn't have to be an actor
to get an emotional response a special
effects artist doesn't have to be a
writer to suck somebody into a new world
so why would anyone expect an actor also
has to be a singer to win an audience
over it's all an illusion anyway and a
better at dazzles the more we forget
we're just sitting in a seat watching a
screen we instead feel like we're being
absorbed into a different environment so
rather than letting poor actors like
Pierce Brosnan
sing solos suffice or Lee Marvin wheels
amazing roll use amazed
and Barriss themselves again just
remember film is a collaborative art
form as long as the focus is taking
people on an amazing journey people are
always ready to hear that music no
matter how it's done or who sings it I'm
on the saundra Critic I remember so you
don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Waterkeeper Alliance this is the world's
fastest-growing environmental movement
with more than 200 local water keepers
patrolling rivers lakes and coastal
waterways on six continents water
keepers defends their communities
against anyone who's painted their right
to clean water they speak with a single
powerful voice as they tackle the
world's most pressing water issues the
Alliance stands behind every water
keeper increasing their ability to
function as community defenders in their
efforts to protect the world's water
with they support them by providing
expertise in science law strategic
planning and communication making them
more effective in their communities
courtrooms and classrooms if you look at
this site in their YouTube page you can
experience all the various ways that
they help people get the clean water
that they deserve this is a great
organization that deserves to get as
much support as I can so click on the
links and see how you two can help
millions of people drink safe
you